foreign
hey guys welcome to episode
280 of congratulations
[Music]
guess what Raleigh I'll be there Friday
Raleigh North Carolina I'll be there
Friday tickets uh there are maybe a few
tickets left
um but it's very close to sold out
Savannah Georgia I'll be there Saturday
um Le there are more tickets available
in Savannah because Savannah apparently
look I sold a lot of tickets so far it's
almost at 2 000 but the venue is a
little bigger than that Savannah doesn't
[ __ ] with your boy like North Carolina
folks with your boy it's all good though
dude he's still in the South North
Carolina Savannah the deeper you go to
the South the more they want to listen
to somebody like you know I don't know
Naper getsy but that's fine
and it's all good I love Nate bargati
he's hilarious um so yeah dude
chrisley.com for tickets I got other
ones that are going fast almost sold out
in New York City uh Chicago getting air
added another show in San Diego uh
Portland Seattle this is the Don't Push
Me Tour go to chrysalia.com Midland
Texas uh Sugarland Texas
um this is off the top of the Franken
Dome Portland Seattle I said
um and uh what do you call it uh the
other one in uh all right well whatever
go to chrisley.com there's money more to
Boston sold I think 200 tickets in
Boston the other day Boston [ __ ] with
your boy
um so yeah
um and that's that wore this the other
day I'll pump I'll pimp this out here
because it got cold
join our join our cult
um and that hoodie because it's hoodie
seasoning so go to chrisley.com get your
hoodies and also we got new uh shirts
available the life rips New Life rip
shirts available chrisley.com but
whatever that's out of the way and uh
we're having a good time you know what
dude I'm not gonna lie to you I've been
waking up later and Franken later
he goes to bed late because he's
watching TV because he's a fat dad yes
he's a fat dad dude I I can't tell you
how often I feel like you know what dude
let's just be a fat a fat guy I'm not a
fat guy I'm not even close to the fact
I'm joking but honestly I just feel like
maybe it'll just be more fun
you know like maybe it'll just be more
fun
maybe I'll just eat pasta and ice cream
and pizza and you know I because the
thing is in the daytime dude I got no
problem eating healthy
the worst I'll do is a turkey sandwich
and that's the worst okay
but
mostly salads stuff without bread in it
maybe some quinoa a little dash of
quinoa
um and then uh when Night comes all hell
breaks loose dude all hell breaks loose
my babies
that's it hey time for hell to go like
this I got the keys
hell's got the keys at night
hell's got the keys
dude hell hell goes like this there's
ice cream out there
[Music]
how it goes like this wait there's Pizza
out there
hell goes oh it's it's thin crust then I
can eat double
hell goes pizza and ice creams out there
holla hey guard come here good guard
against the bars
huh
always wanted to do that hey guard come
here
come on into the thing
that's a that's a real badass move dude
and then kiss them
um
but yeah dude uh
uh so yeah I don't know man
I just I maybe I'll just be a fat guy at
some point I don't know sometimes I see
people and they got older and I haven't
seen them in a long time and they're
just fat and I'm like you know what I'm
like I'm I don't I guess some people are
like well you look like [ __ ] I'm just
like dude maybe you figured it out
like how much does how much is this
cancer you're getting worth
it worth
10 years I don't know I mean some people
just see 85 and they're like you know
hello sometimes you people who are not
70 and they're just like hey but
sometimes people 75 are jumping off
desks and [ __ ] you ever see Jack LaLanne
I think he's still alive he's 150.
um but yeah man
you know eating leaves how much fun are
you having
you you put too much dressing on you get
a diet cancer anyway so it's just like
you know
maybe I just want to be a fat guy or
just like a an out of shape guy you know
I don't know man
you know I like to keep it lean but also
ice cream so good and then also it's
just like watching everything on like
Hulu and Amazon and Amazon Prime and HBO
Max and and Netflix it's just like dude
maybe I'll just maybe I'll just maybe
I'll just give hell the keys
because
there's so many things on like I watched
that Watcher show and then I watched I
was done watching The Watcher show and
then I watched just so many like like
even Kristen the other day was like
let's go see Lyle Crocodile with Calvin
and I was like yes dude that sounds like
such a nice family outing but then all
of a sudden I was like think of all the
couch sitting I won't be doing
think about that think about all the
food and I don't mean popcorn I mean
actual food I won't because I like to be
comfortable just like the next person
but when you get too comfortable
involved when you get the couch sitting
watching that's three comfortables
involved the couch sitting chilling
watching a TV show or a movie chilling
and then also putting food in your mouth
chilling that's three comfortables right
so the more comfortable is involved you
can't have too many comfortables right
you definitely can't have too many
comfortable like if you're on the couch
eating watching the thing and somebody's
giving you an OTP HJ not good too many
comfortables right I would argue that
that's not even a comfortable that's a
pleasurable
you can't do a pleasure feeding eating
is a little bit of a pleasurable but
it's more comfortable if you couple it
with right
watching a TV show and then also setting
an account couch that's too comfortables
and that pleasurable turns into a
comfortable right but if you add a note
to phj Absolute too much that's that's
too pleasurables that now connect each
other and become a bigger pleasurable so
that's really
too comfortables and too pleasurables
and they cancel each other out you might
as well be standing in the middle of a
field right
but my point is
you know you link these comfortables up
you feel real nice you link these
pleasurables up it's too much it's
distracting it's like that guy who
always was having orgasms what that
what's that condition where the guy just
can't stop having orgasms and he'll just
be like and he told the press and the
Press was like so what's it like and he
was like well you know I just sit
and uh you know it's it happens every
few seconds and if I'm lucky it'll
happen every minute uh but yeah I just
can't I simply cannot
and you're just like sitting there like
that's too many pleasurables right like
you wouldn't want an orgasm all the time
but
um
anyway dude
so we went to go see lilac crocodile I
the here's the thing okay we saw Lala
crocodile I thought it was going to be
absolutely Bonkers because I'm gonna go
group with cap but because I was like
because I was like I'm missing out on
couch setting time but like let's do
this for the sun because I want Calvin
to have a happy life and I don't want to
see crocodile but he wants to see a lot
of crocodile and what does that make me
do makes me want to kind of see la la
crocodile because I want to share the
experience with them right now I don't
live for myself I live for someone
outside of me never thought that would
have happened in 2016. yet here I am
but the couch sitting time right and I
can still kind of get couch sitting time
with Calvin but she's like but let's go
and I'm like what about the couch
setting time but then she's like I pick
movie theaters and I'm like
oh she wants to lay down get a blanket
and press a button and have the waiter
come during the whole movie
but do they have but do they have
pretzels with with cheese yes they do
yes they do but do they have chicken
tacos yes they do oh yes they do they
have pizza that they make yes they do
dude
the iPic Theaters
you can go to a movie and be in either
big be an even bigger fat slot than go
to AMC you could literally
chillax dude and I'm just like I don't
even know how much it is it's probably
it's you know it's it's like a whole
date night if you're gonna go but I went
with Kristen and Calvin and we went to
go see a lot of crocodile first of all
there's a book called the LA crocodile
that I read actually that was one of
those books that I skipped over even
when I was a kid I've seen it but I
skipped over it right but when lilac
crocodile came to the movie I was like
oh I remember this [ __ ] but then I'm
like why don't they just call it Lyle
the crocodile as a movie
like it's cute for a book but for a
movie with Javi Bardem
so I'm like let's watch this movie who's
in it that Constance woo woman who you
know and also the
skeeter mcdeeter or whatever the hell
his name is scoop McNary right good
actor so I'm like let's go see Lala
crocodile
then uh we get there and Calvin is so
excited at the iPic Theater he sits down
he's waiting and and dude this little
kid comes on the the before the movie
preview and he's eating a hamburger talk
about all the food at I pick Calvin sees
the kitty can't stop laughing at the kid
we're eating a hamburger dude he's just
laughing at the kitty the hamburger so
I'm like this could be great dude he's
about to see a singing crocodile
he's going to have the time of his life
he killed it at Super Pets he killed it
at bad guys he killed it at saying two
the dude was locked in like he was ready
for ready to test g-forces I mean my son
watched movies the whole time like he
was ready to test g-forces and I don't
mean he was like testing g-forces I mean
he was ready like okay guys Anything
could happen here I might pass out I
might have the time of my life and I
might celebrate afterwards but here we
go that's how my son was watching these
movies Super Pets bad guys and also sing
too now I wasn't there for sync two that
was his first movie because it kind of
snuck it on me felt bad that I didn't go
to his first movie so she left the
theater and then we went to go see bad
guys all good
I want to be there for every one of my
sons first is that feasible no but I
want to be but he wants to be
right I want to be there for every one
of my sons first why because I'm such a
[ __ ] good dad and I had no idea I
would be yet I am yeah here I am
five years later out the Flames loving
the [ __ ] out of my son and my family
that's how locking back up and going you
know I'll stay in here for a bit
um so yeah la la crocodile starts and
um
you know I don't want to do like a
review of Lyle Lyle Crocodile because
this is a podcast for adults right
um but uh
sucks donkey ball sucks donkey balls
sucks donkey balls and um even for a
kids movie it makes sense these kids
movies dude for real they don't have to
make sense but but but hey
hey though hey though also do me a favor
right hey guys you can make it make
sense you know how I know
The English Patient is a movie okay so
just do a kid version of it making sense
of that
it doesn't have to make sense because my
son will watch blippi
it doesn't have to make sense because my
son will watch b b this is the letter B
[ __ ] song
I I
this is the letter I uh uh igloo
w w
this is the letter W
why is this my career
wha why is my life my wife leaving me
I'll do it
that's a killing that that song rips for
real dude you'll be singing it later on
your kid watching it and he's just like
liking it you're like this is [ __ ]
and then later on at the bank you're
just like [ __ ] Jay
just here to make a deposit
so uh but my point is universal
Touchstone doesn't even exist anymore
Columbia Pictures Orion do me fave
Pixar seems to have a handle on it
thanks
but do me fave
if you're making a lot of crocodile I
get my kiddo just watch literally a
crocodile singing and dancing
but you know what though dude movie hey
Hollywood do me fave okay
because honestly I'm sitting there and
I'm like Jesus Christ now what do all of
the movies that Calvin have seen have in
common super bets bad guys sing two
animation
what does this one not have one of these
things is not like the other lilac
crocodile live anime live uh live action
so we're watching it and I'm noticing
Calvin watches it for a little bit and
then gets Restless why because nobody is
literally a cartoon singing in his face
do you like mushrooms
do you like mushrooms yes I do do you
like popsicles
yes I do do you like mushroom popsicles
yucky
no I don't
so now my son not only has to see a
crocodile singing and dancing he's also
got to see an actual real life Constance
woo say well we can't tell your father
he's got to see Javi Bardem he's got to
see 60 year old Javi B over there like
this is going to make me lots of money
right
and my son doesn't care how many colors
Javi bees got on
he's sitting there like where's the
mushroom popsicle
so now not only is he
you know doing tumbles in his seat all
laid back not only is he running around
throwing the chicken fingers that we got
from iPic and the ranch sauce only
dipping fingers in his not even eating
the chicken right not only is he doing
that but I'm sitting there and I'm like
Hollywood's doing me no favors by just
having this crocodile not taught the
crackers I can't talk you can only sing
dude if you can sing you can talk right
if you can sing just do the easier
version of that and do it or if you can
sing how about you like she'd ask him
like what's going on today and he would
just be like
and then when she needed help with
cooking he was like you grab the spatula
and then you just did the pancakes it's
like dude you can sing how you are today
too dude just sing Everything be like
James Corden he [ __ ] doesn't he sing
like I feel like James Corden sings 65
of the [ __ ] that comes out of his mouth
so it's just like
I'm sitting there and Hollywood's doing
me no favors and [ __ ] Calvin sitting
there rolling around throwing [ __ ]
cheese fries and [ __ ]
Lila loud crocodile is an abomination of
a movie all right and I mean that also
even as like a who's it for
who is it for is my question Super Pets
yes sing two uh bad guys the bad guys
with the [ __ ] Fox and the snake and
[ __ ] that's for kids because they get to
get my sons too he's locked in I told
you
Lala crocodile where the crocodile only
sings and there's only one crocodile in
it and the rest is live action and it's
like who's that for my two-year-old's
all over the place is a nine-year-old
gonna want to watch that no in nine
years gonna want to watch Hawkeye dude
foreign
God it's so much better when you get the
timing dude timing is [ __ ] goddamn
everything so
um
[Music]
guys let's take a break I want to talk
to you about ship station It's the Most
Wonderful Time of the Year okay it's
coming up whether you like it or not
it's absolutely wonderful the holidays
are coming up but guess what it's also
the most hectic time of the year and
that's a huge problem isn't it okay
everyone puts off shopping until last
minute and if you have an online store
you know the feeling of getting hit with
tons of orders at once it all happens
immediately in the book of an eye so
when you're buried in orders and emails
from stress from stress customers you'll
wish you had ship station if you have an
e-commerce an online store ship station
is the way to go it turns holiday ship
storms into smooth sailing so you can
keep your customers happy and still find
time to enjoy some eggnog do it now
because it's easier now than later you
get all bogged down I use ship station
and
um you know I have ship petition in my
corner and it's a beautiful thing I am
uh you know totally chilled I'm
chillaxed which is a word I don't even
say but sometimes that's necessary uh
for this holiday season and my my uh my
business online there's just no stress
because I know shipstation can handle it
now uh we've got a deal for you guys
here uh at my podcast but uh before I
get into that no one wants to think that
hard during the holidays okay
ship station is a no-brainer they help
you not think you get to just chill
shift station works with all your
favorite uh places to sell online
including Amazon Etsy eBay Shopify you
name it uh you save time and money and
most importantly stress uh when you sign
up using my promo code you'll get even
two months to try it free two months to
try it free
um this holiday season give yourself the
gift of stress-free holiday shipping use
promo code congrats today at
shipstation.com to sign up for your free
60-day trial that's two months guys if
you're bad at math that's
shipstation.com promo code congrats
crazy crazy
uh yeah so look man we watched it and uh
and I will say this okay
I'm watching this movie and I'm just
like it's bad the acting is bad the
[ __ ]
which means the directing is bad if all
of the actors are bad the director is
bad if all of the actors are good the
director is good period that's how it is
okay
Javi B shows up dude all right
Javier Bardem javibe shows up dude now
Javi B shows up in a [ __ ] outfit that
would make like Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory go like you're wearing
that
all right
[ __ ] Willy Wonka
javibe shows up dude and this guy
and I'm not this is not a joke dude
he arrests you
you're in the theater
and he arrests you dude you go where are
we going
because I'm on a ride dude he's so good
in this movie and then I realize
Javi B is one of the most
absolute greatest actor greatest actors
of our time because I'm sitting here
watching Javi B and his Florida Gators
shirt and hat with the [ __ ] pubes
coming out the sides right
pretending he's hanging with a crocodile
because it's not real but he's I mean
this guy is just like doing all sorts of
oh you know dancing and grabbing his
hand and twisting with the [ __ ] big
ass crocodile
laughing like [ __ ] is really funny
I mean this dude's on another level man
and I'm watching this and then I'm like
and I I actually have a thought
wait a minute hold on I thought this guy
was in No Country for Old Men but maybe
he isn't because this guy's different I
had to Google it afterwards
for those of you that don't know if it
is or it is it is him
he completely envelops the character
Javi B it goes like this dude Christian
Bale
let me tell you something dude there are
actors that cannot people I'm gonna
point I'm gonna name three actors that
do things that actors just can't do
all right there's not many of them there
are more than who I'm saying but these
are the three that come to mind all
right
Christian Bale
Sean Penn
Daniel Day-Lewis
and Javi now let me tell you what when I
say Javi because here's the thing those
three actors can do things that nobody
can do Javi B main like there's a guy
who can do what Javi B did in um la la
crocodile like you know Nathan Lane or
[ __ ] you know uh the guy from Will
and Grace the the the the really
flamboyant one that dude would kill
but could he be in No Country for Old
Men no dude imagine Nathan Lane in No
Country for Old Men with the [ __ ]
like shooting the cow in the head with
the [ __ ] well it's time to die how
pain you know
but dude
the range though
but that range that Javi B has that
range that Javier Bardem goes like I
would like to play lilac crocodile
that range but and then it goes are you
sure you were No Country for Old Men and
he goes like this watch how I show up
happy as [ __ ]
pubes coming out the side of the [ __ ]
Top Hat Florida Gator shirt on
suspenders all the way up
just like where is the crocodile it
doesn't matter it's not here I will
still have a good time I pretend like it
is here
his [ __ ] is phenomenal dude I am telling
you right now and this is no joke he
deserves to get nominated for an Oscar
for Lala crocodile along and I don't
think he should win I think Austin
Butler should win but he should be I
mean dude I haven't seen all the movies
I get it and everyone's talking about oh
like this and that the other thing and
this movie is good like somebody wants
me to see Kate Blanchett and [ __ ] tar
and I'm just like past dude
you know pass that movie is so full of
itself
I can tell by the preview
I'm sure she's great also that's a
different best female performance but
you know
my God Javi B
that guy's one of my favorite actors now
and I was sitting now I'm watch and when
Javi Javier shows up the wall according
I'm like this okay good good thank God I
mean this guy
Hollywood do I mean no favor but boy are
the [ __ ] this Spaniard comes in and
he's just [ __ ] saving the day I love
Javier Bardem and
I don't mean to make this whole podcast
about Javier Bardem but sexy is all get
out
I mean come on dude at least Sean boy
when Sean Penn played I am Sam I go like
this this guy you know how Christian
Bale loses weight or gains weight and
does that [ __ ] remember we need
advice and he played uh what's his name
the vice president what was his name
Dick Cheney played Dick Cheney and he
just cursed about just like great I'll
just say pizza and hot dogs I mean he
was giving hell the keys for that no
doubt dude and he just plumped the [ __ ]
up and he probably pulled his hair out
too same for the American Hustle but
then he got really skinny for the
machine machinist and they got really
skinny and then beefed up right
afterward for Batman
I mean dude what Christian Bale does
with his weight honestly for acting I
swear to God Sean Penn did with Down
syndrome and I am Sam that dude got it
for three months
he [ __ ] got it for three months
if you watch dude look at this here's
how you know if somebody's a good actor
or not
Google a still image of them in a
character
ah dude Google is still image
Google is still image of the person
in the in the movie I'll put a still I'm
gonna put a still image of somebody
writing of Sean Penn right here in I am
Sam it's gonna be right here I haven't
get rid of gonna do it look at that look
at that image dude and the Oscar for
best
still image goes to
Sean Penn and I am Sam this is Sean
Penn's first still image Oscar
for playing a downside look at that
picture he obviously has has Incredible
strength and a big head
great we'll get [ __ ] flagged for that
but you know what I mean dude
you know what I'm saying it's a comedy
podcast we already can't [ __ ] get it
gang what's up with the subscribers
YouTube it's because we got caught in
the name or whatever whatever do we
write it out you can't keep us down
[Music]
and the and the award for Oscar for best
still image this year goes to Javi B for
Lyle Lyle Crocodile him with the
suspenders like this and you get it dude
if you if somebody acts good in a
picture that person dude and I can do
that I can do that 100 I can do that
you know so I'm telling you if you get
me I know I haven't been in movies
lately Holly and I'm not even like you
know I've had I've actually had some
offers I go I don't know I don't know
the way I don't know I'd rather just
[ __ ] go on stage and just absolutely
oblit I'd rather go on stage but talk
about my truth but also obliterate right
but also take some laws and talk about
what's happening but I also you know I'm
not sure about Hollywood but boy if I
get on a [ __ ] if if I get in a movie
again dude
it's a problem it's a problem on screen
I don't mean on set with Shenanigans
it's a problem on screen dude
best still Oscar for best still photo
goes to me dude
I don't give a [ __ ] I'll play anybody
I'll play an Asian with no makeup
I'll play [ __ ] I'll do I'll do the
Javi B story I play Javier Barb Dam a
Spaniard growing up in the [ __ ] 40s
or 50s whatever it was
60s Maybe
but he's sexy as I'll get out though
isn't he he really is Google the [ __ ]
picture of Javier Javier Bardem 20 years
ago oh my God the guy just would little
literally hand out towels while he
walked on the street to women I know you
probably need this yes you probably need
this right if you're going to sit down
you should probably put this on first
right oh look a snail Trail hello yes oh
you already saw me I see you're leaking
I see yes we thought they were dark
jeans but they're just wet here you go
handing out jeans and [ __ ] towels
hello yes you have met Javier bread then
dude how
how am I dude why
actually I grew up into my looks and
then once I grew up I know I know you
like the scruffy look you're lucky I
don't shave because I'm actually a good
clean shaven too how many guys can be
like that here is a towel and here are
some new jeans they're light
I probably have so many children I have
no idea
and I have talent
um
God how much is he a [ __ ] great
father probably too you know just my
hero
whatever dude I talked about [ __ ]
Javier but I'm way too long in this
podcast but sometimes the podcast calls
for what it calls for right you can't
just [ __ ] Force some [ __ ]
you know you can't come on here and be
like yeah but I've got an agenda and I
want to talk about this who am I [ __ ]
what am I you know CNN
I come on here and I let the [ __ ] unfold
dude I'm a I'm a real journalist over
here
foreign
these movies man I love couch sitting
and obviously I love couch sitting so
much guess what I started doing Wordle
Dude Killing It 92 success rate okay so
so what what does that mean I missed one
out of 12 so far I've been doing for 12
straight days yeah he plays world so
what he gets mostly gets it in four or
five
but uh world is crazy it's at the
[ __ ] it's one of those things you go
to world.com or some [ __ ] and I'm doing
Wordle and I'm killing it having a good
time and then I [ __ ] tell my mom
about how I love World she's like I love
world too and then she goes like this
you ever heard of quartal and I go like
this Ma
this is like the time when you I don't
this
my mom will do [ __ ] like this where like
I'm like we're like at dinner
and she's like do you know what you're
gonna get and I'm like yeah I think the
burger looks great and she'll be like oh
okay but they have Meatloaf I don't know
if you saw and now I'm conflicted dude I
already gave you a definitive answer but
you're gonna throw [ __ ] I didn't see
the meatloaf and now I don't know what I
was totally happy and content
right
I am somebody that when the government
says we don't want to tell the public
this I go like this good don't tell us
this [ __ ] you'll figure it out that's me
at dinner and my mom's the government
like well we got to let the public know
they have meatloaf and now I'm the
general public population in turmoil
there's Mutiny going on inside me
half of me wants a burger and half of me
wants the meatloaf
so you know
she tells me about quartile and I'm like
at this point my mom says have you heard
of Squirtle and I go and honestly I'm 20
sure now that maybe my mom has actually
gone senile because I'm like what are
you making [ __ ] up she goes there's four
four
squares there's not just one square
there's four of them and you keep
guessing letters and you have to get all
four and I go that sounds horrible and
she says it's fun
and I say all right I'll try it and I
try it that night and let me [ __ ]
tell you something dude when I tried it
that night dude I was doing that I mean
dude I was doing you can only do them
once a day what the [ __ ] up with
Wordle or quarter you can only do them
once a day that's [ __ ] I want one of
I want to do them more than once stop
gifting me this [ __ ] I know the idea is
to I don't understand it to me it's a
bad business plan like I want to do more
and more and more and more I want to
play it as much as I can dude when I did
Bananagrams I did it [ __ ] all day
imagine people saying that's like giving
one somebody one Lays Potato Chip I want
the whole [ __ ] thing and then I'll
eat more and then you'll make more money
right
but dude so I'm playing [ __ ] Wordle
and yeah it's fun and and then I [ __ ]
I'm like let me try this quartile thing
it's not gonna be good but sure enough
and now I'm playing Wardle and quartal
and eat some [ __ ] 25 minutes right
so I'm just like couch sitting doing
wordling chordal I see Mama my mom again
she goes
so was I right about quartile or what
and I and I said yeah quarto's actually
really great and we're sharing each
other our scores you know I've got
relationship with my mommy
and she says
you should try
oh total
there's eight boxes hey
foreign
[Laughter]
craze dude leave it at quarto
I mean OCT Turtle doesn't even sound
good
is it about a [ __ ]
shelled animal
she goes you should try octodal it's
really fun and I say dude you know what
I can't I'm not I go I go OCT turtle
where's the [ __ ] thing
miles done
come on man
so I didn't do octoadal yet but I have a
feeling [ __ ] next week I'm gonna come
in and be like yo oh Turtles the [ __ ]
dude that's how I do it I say nah [ __ ]
that [ __ ] cause here's the thing anytime
I'm like Russian dude anytime someone
says you should try this I go like this
what do you [ __ ] secretly want from
me are you a Cuda are you just seeing
somebody's shiny bracelet and trying to
snatch that up because you think you
want it or do you actually understand
the value of the diamond bracelet and
how you can resell it later and this or
are you just want to wear it to [ __ ]
flaws are you a secret Cuda cause I'm
rushing with this [ __ ] man you can't
just be all like
telling me to do [ __ ] I'm involved my
grandfather my grandfather bam that was
his name his name was grandfa his name
is Vincent but they called him bam
because when he was young he was skinny
as a bamboo
but my grandpa bam always said never
volunteer for anything and when my dad
said my grandpa said that when I was
younger I go like this wee meme I'm like
oh yeah
why would you volunteer for anything
then they got you
are you the kind of person that says oh
yeah let me plug my email in for the
they gotcha
did you ever do the 23andMe to find out
your [ __ ] what'd you find out huh oh
what'd you find out you [ __ ] got five
percent bottaswanian
at ya
I don't do 23andMe I don't type in my
email for a [ __ ] 10 discount
they gotcha
they can control you now I'm not Alex
Jones but I'm telling you dude
we stop
at quarto
now tomorrow when I start doing octoral
the whole [ __ ] thing is
I say [ __ ] this [ __ ] that I don't want
to be doing that and then I get into it
and then I really get into it and all my
friends make fun of me said you said
[ __ ] that [ __ ] and then I'd say well you
know it's good to have an open mind and
then I say you got to start doing
octoadal and then they're like I don't
want to do the [ __ ] [ __ ] and I get
all them involved and they keep doing it
and then I find something else because I
got addiction baby and when I found out
something I like I run it into the
ground Maybe
um
so yeah dude
there's octoadal out there trying to
cash in on the on the order uh on the
order craze um
but it's a nice it's a nice it's a nice
game I like I don't really like games I
like things by myself right like I don't
ever want to like people are always like
why don't you want to play Ultimate
Frisbee why don't you want to go golfing
you know let's do a tandem bike ride and
I'm just like dude if I'm gonna do this
[ __ ] it's me versus me
it's I don't wanna or or me versus one
other person but it's like like I did
Jiu Jitsu for five six years but still
that's kind of Me versus me right
bowling I gotta play against somebody I
don't wanna do that it's not really me
versus me
but like baseball
football
I can blame other people
if it's just me it's just me if I [ __ ]
up on Wordle it's just me dude
unless they do you know there's [ __ ]
you know someone's nagging me from the
background or some shit's deeper but um
yeah I don't like that I don't I like
only when it's just me me versus me
um
I mean that might have been the title of
the show me versus me except for the
fact that hell's got the keys is such a
[ __ ] rip-run awesome title that you
know that's what it has to be
um
we were at my parents this is when I was
with my mom told me about octoadal
octoadal total you know
uh we went to uh we're in we were
knocking you out of visiting my parents
and then Kristen says can I have uh your
your wallet I need to buy something and
I say sure right because I know she's
very cool with the money it's not like
she's gonna buy like a [ __ ] you know
jet ski
we're on the way home got two jet skis
um
so I say okay uh sure she gets picks my
wife said what are you buying she said
just something I'm like okay all right
all right weird you're not but okay so
then uh we are leaving and she's like
let's go by 8 45 and I'm like okay
and I'm like what's going on here and
she says we should leave at 8 45 because
we want to go to Verdugo we should go to
Verdugo sorry sorry uh uh uh Descanso
Gardens
and I'm like Descanso Gardens it's like
a [ __ ] cool like tree plant
Garden
in locking out it's beautiful people go
from all over the place and uh I you've
never been I grew up in La Canada and
I've never been to [ __ ] Descanso
Gardens isn't that crazy I've literally
never been you've been how many times
never been he's been 10 never have you
yeah he's gonna be living on Kenyatta
so uh grew up there never went because
me I'm always like what there's so
there's lots of plants okay
me I'm like okay so there's some big
trees that do crazy twirly shits okay
fine I could Google that
but Kristen wants to go and I say huh
okay but it's dark and she says that's
the thing
they got a whole Halloween get up and I
say really and I say yeah cow's gonna
love it it's one of the only things that
you can do for a two-year-old that isn't
scary as [ __ ] and they say oh really did
you look that up or is that something
that you think right because this is you
know my OCD work in overtime and she
says uh oh well no uh it actually says
like not scary farm and Universal and
all that [ __ ] the Halloween Horror
Nights you shouldn't go for anywhere
under 13 and I'm like 13. Jesus okay
fine
so just kind of gardens it is it was
like one of the only things right
besides you unless you want to go to a
pumpkin patch but those are all closed
at [ __ ] nine so she's like I got
tickets to go from nine to ten so I'm
like what is this Gonzo Gardens what is
this Halloween thing and she says I
don't know and I said well you looked it
up right and she's like yeah it's like
they got like you know Halloween stuff
and I was like so but what is it and she
says oh I I I I I don't know and she
says stop asking me I don't really know
and I said well we're going we should
know what it is anyway we didn't it
wasn't like an argument but I'm like
whatever and then so I said Calvin will
go ask Mommy what it is so she'll answer
you because she won't answer me and she
goes and it was a little second moment
but it's all good so we went
to Descanso Gardens
and our tickets were from nine to ten I
don't know why you had tickets but you
just I guess it would get overcrowded
and let me tell you something dude
my son had such an uncle blast dude
he saw so many pumpkins man
there were so many freaking pumpkins so
many beautiful pumpkins that they carved
you know they had like a
um
but I had like a moment there that was
totally unexpected that I was blindsided
from
we get to this kind of Gardens and we're
walking around a little bit my my son's
saying like you know I got pumpkin pants
on and he does they're glow in the dark
I got a pumpkin shirt on she's another
girl with a pumpkin shirt on he says to
her I got a pumpkin shirt on it's cool
it's called carved is what it is at uh
uh Verdugo I keep saying Jesus Descanso
Gardens Verdugo hospitals right next to
it and don't know why I keep doing that
but um so
we are
walking through it and the this kind of
gardens is like this really big setup
area that's also it I mean it's like
there's stuff that's built in it like
like like benches and like a small
outdoor stage and then there's like you
know
um like stuff that's like obviously
planted like a bit of flowers and
there's a huge beautiful tree that if
you chopped it down you'd probably get
like [ __ ] 90 years in prison and uh
and uh it's it's just like there's like
lights and stuff that are put up and
they really deck it out for Halloween
though
and there's like I mean I'm talking
about if there's if there's a hundred
pumpkins there's there's got to be 800
pumpkins lit up like jack-o-lanterns I
mean right some of them are carved in
like with like movies like they got a
Batman one they got a [ __ ] you know
Encanto one for kids and [ __ ] my son's
looking at the Minions One
uh uh and uh
I'm walking with Calvin and my Calvin's
just having a blast I mean he's really
visual it's not like a lot of crocodiles
like he's [ __ ] arrested watching sing
too like really locked in like about to
go for that GeForce testing and he looks
at these benches almost like pews and
this outdoor stage and there's this big
Skeleton on this outdoor stage
and uh candles and all this [ __ ] lit up
for Halloween and Calvin looks at it and
he walks towards it and he keeps saying
what
what
he takes four or five steps and he says
what
look at this skeleton what and it's
hysterical okay because I'm his dad it's
it's honestly not that crazy
but it's blowing his [ __ ] mind or
he's seen me do this about something and
now he's just recreating it I don't know
either way it's hilarious
and we're passing these pews he walks
all the way up to the skeleton and he's
just saying what
what and I'm sitting next to him looking
at him right up at the skeleton and then
I I don't actually look at the skeleton
because my whole thing is
when I'm watching a movie with my son or
we're experiencing something new I don't
watch the thing I watch my son because I
want to although experience this with
him I really want to take in how much he
loves and is experiencing this new thing
so I'm looking at him
and Kristen is standing behind me and I
realize her energy changes and it's not
a big thing but it's like a very small
minute thing that I think honestly only
I could probably
feel because I'm her husband
and she puts her hand on Calvin's
shoulder and then I look up at the
skeleton and it's got a bunch of
pictures of children on it with candles
and I realize that these are children
that have
passed away
and Kristen says okay Calvin come over
here and we go to sit down on the bench
to I guess you know pay our respects you
know
I didn't realize
it was just it was odd because Calvin's
saying what what and there's comedy in
that but there was also a very weighty
sadness that I wasn't even aware of
until I was aware of it and Calvin was
never aware of it
and
um we sit on the bench
and Calvin sitting with me and I'm
I'm just hit with like this very
um
strong
mix of feelings of how of how lucky I am
that I have this and how sad this is
um
and how I'm well aware of this and
Calvin isn't to me it's to him it's just
this big skeleton that's just
incredulous
and Calvin walks away with Kristen and I
sit there and I just start [ __ ]
crying dude like it all hit me about how
like just blindsided me about how sad
this is that this is the reality that we
live in and I'm so fortunate and you're
so fortunate to live every day with
somebody that you love because that
could be just [ __ ] ripped from you
and at any moment
and so we did that and that was kind of
in the beginning of of uh
of uh the Descanso Gardens thing and you
know
it's like when I say life rips it's like
those are the moments where you really
have to [ __ ] take that in
um and then we leave at the end of it we
were there for about an hour and we
leave and then we drive home
Kristen goes to bed a little later and
Calvin I we put him down and and I went
downstairs and I just started thinking
about
these
children and these families of these
children uh you know this is
uh
after I watched the movie till death
with Megan Fox uh it really has no
bearing on it just kind of like the
just kind of [ __ ] them give the big
idiot I am you know what I mean just
watching a [ __ ] Megan Fox movie
because it's on Netflix and I'm just and
I just go oh give it a try and uh
after this movie I just I'm just sitting
and I'm like should I eat something I
start thinking about these children and
um I just I get so sad and I and I start
crying again like
um
because I I I I I I realize I'm I I live
in uh I'm I'm I have this fear
of um
of this world being so chaotic
and I have this fear of like
being a father and a parent in this
world when there's so much craziness out
there
and I start panicking and I had a I
would say a panic attack not a
full-blown I've had bad panic attacks
before a few a couple uh but this one
was
right up there I mean I I started crying
and like I couldn't understand why I I I
I I should feel fortunate
you know and I was just I was literally
crying because I was scared which I
don't think I've ever done before unless
I you know on since I was Calvin's age
um
and it was just a really weird unique
experience and um
I I you know I cried for like [ __ ] 30
minutes
and then I went to bed and I couldn't
fall asleep
and I finally fell asleep
I was just like I hope that I wake up
tomorrow and I feel okay and I woke up
the next morning and I felt better but
not all better and then that's today
um and I kept thinking how am I gonna do
this podcast but um I did I just you
know and I think it's going well and
it's fun you know had a lot of
interesting things to say about Javier
Bardem but and and and and and and
quartile but uh
it's just like real life [ __ ] keeps
happening dude that's the craziest thing
you know when I was in before I was
really like in in therapy and really
dealing with like my my self and my
emotions and [ __ ] and just kind of
living
uh for pleasure uh and selfishly
um
I would have never thought about this
[ __ ] and now that I do it's so [ __ ]
uncomfortable for me
um
but like I also I also had therapy today
and it was brutal like I was like really
like emotional during the therapy and
then afterwards I felt
a little better I feel a little better
now
um
I don't know man I don't even know what
I'm trying to say it's just like [ __ ]
I mean we deal with all these emotions
as people and like even as like a funny
we're having a great time and then a sad
time and then a [ __ ] another good time
it's like even in this podcast like you
know this podcast used to be [ __ ]
silly goose times strictly and now it's
silly goose times [ __ ] absolutely 75
of the time but every now and then I
gotta tell you how I'm feeling dude and
I gotta tell you how I'm feeling because
like uh
I don't owe it to anybody but I just
want to I'm 42 and I implore you guys to
[ __ ] do the same man you know
somebody called into Lifeline Lifeline
my other podcast here on super call
Studios and they were talking about how
their husband uh it won't do therapy and
um it's just like I think it's really
beneficial man I was talking to my
tattoo artist the other day about
therapy
um I got this
the elevator with the heart in it
people you keep asking me what it means
I'll talk about it one day but
it does great work man huh
does great work man so now I told him
either I'm like this or like this in my
podcast you'll always see one of your
designs the dude's good
um yeah
it's a crazy world out there
I did watch that movie till death of
Megan Fox dude and I'm not I like
you know Megan Fox and Machine Gun Kelly
they're dating and it's super annoying
but
um you know I I love I love Machine Gun
Kelly I love uh uh
well I don't know anything about Megan
Fox right
um except for she's dating him and she
was in Transformers and um and that
movie Jennifer's Body
um and I know nothing about her at all
and uh I'm always annoyed when two
famous people are dating and I have to
see it all the time right so uh
and so I'm watching this movie till
death I just put it on and I'm like this
is gonna be [ __ ] shitty just because
most movies are shitty and that's going
to be a safe bet and then I [ __ ]
I'm gonna start watching it dude you
know Megan Fox is a good actress
she's good
she this movie was a fine movie no it
was a fine script and the way that it
was directed and the way that Megan Fox
did it tonally she elevated the [ __ ]
project dude congratulations to [ __ ]
Megan Fox for real she's good she was
[ __ ] good dude in this movie
I don't know if that [ __ ] is
something to even talk about but it's
just like dude
congrats to her
I guess Kanye's buying parlor this guy
it's like
this guy just can't stay out of the
[ __ ] media media stop it
I guess it gets clicks this whole [ __ ]
playing parlor because Elon Musk bought
Twitter you know Kanye West bought to
buy conservative social media platform
parlor
because he was locked out of Twitter and
Instagram for anti-semitic posts who
wants to be
this the thing to me it's like when I
when I when a when a white guy says the
n-word or like when anybody is
anti-symatic anti-Semitic
like freedom is speech I understand but
why do you want to say the n-word so bad
like it's so easy just just to not do it
yeah but freedom of speech okay fine but
why though that why who cares that much
if you care so much about free speech to
that you're like I should be able to say
the n-word on Twitter then you're it you
may not be racist but but why do you
care that much
so it's like it's picking out a little
bit
I get words are just words but also why
like you can absolutely just say the N
word in reference or hey somebody said
this and say it and not be racist but
why do you want to say it so bad is my
point
if I say hey he said the n-word and
don't say the N word and I say the word
that doesn't make me racist but I can
easily say the n-word
that's the whole thing I don't get about
it it's like he's going on an
anti-semitic now granted I didn't read
everything you said I I saw a few things
it seemed like he was saying stuff
against Jews so the fact that he's like
[ __ ] that I'm gonna go to parlor so I
can say this stuff why though
maybe look inward maybe look inward
right
we all should look inward
like you can be on parlor and not be a
piece of [ __ ] I don't think that like
it's got the media has this [ __ ] you
know biased against parlor because you
know it's got this whole like
you know bigot connotation which I have
no idea I've never been on it I have no
no idea but like you can be on par you
could get the part of that be on parlor
and it doesn't mean you're [ __ ] you're a
bigot right
um but if you want to do anti-semitic
[ __ ] or say the n-word it's super weird
you know like I was kind of gonna feel
when the guys are popping off with the
n-word
on parlor
I'm going to get parlor
uh how big is parlor is it big how many
people are on parlor I'ma look how many
people users
on par here we go
uh how many people use parlor 2022
what
oh that was 2021.
um
no
last year it was 32 000 new downloads so
here earlier 20 maybe so the current
stats of parlor shows that there are
over 16 million registers users
registered users in 2022 earlier in 2012
social media platform was 20 million for
its own continuation since its return to
the Apple Store it is oh wow they went
back I didn't know that it has
experienced
32 000 new downloads overall the first
10 days of January saw 870 000 new years
across Apple devices
okay so it has so that's so many
different numbers what does it have you
know
can you get you I guess you can't get
banned from parlor
um
a million active users
this movie that came out in 2017.
Urban myths I saw this the other day and
it's just like hi hi can I help me I'm
looking for that okay we're watching it
okay he plays Bob Dylan pretty cool Ben
shop and could carry grounds guy plays
Samuel Beckett all good fine whatever
you guys playing Adolf Hitler okay
that's fine Elizabeth Taylor Marley
Brian Cox plays Marlon Brando hey though
Joe Joe fine plays Michael Jackson
have you seen this yet 2017.
dude he plays Michael Jackson here it's
got to be here
I sense the dangerous
[Music]
sounds Bruce was trying to kill his
monkey through games
what the [ __ ] bro twice
I mean
just a white guy
dude in 2017 I made this movie isn't it
crazy how and how much five years have
changed who the [ __ ] if they were gonna
make a Michael Jackson movie they would
have to get a black guy to do it right
which is hilarious because he's so he's
white he's whiter than a white guy it'll
be so much easier to just get a white
guy and do a little makeup you know but
they'd have to get a [ __ ] an actual
black guy
wow
insane and honestly I would argue that
that's insane in the membrane
this is the thing okay so this was anti
anti-semitic Kanye West tweeted this I'm
a bit sleepy tonight but when I wake up
I'm going Defcon 3 on Jewish people in
caps wow the funny thing is I actually
can't be anti-semitic because black
people are not are actually Jews so
you guys have toyed with me and tried to
blackball anyone who opposes your agenda
dude my favorite part about this tweet
is
I'm a bit sleepy tonight
what
there's so many things like you don't
like
how about how about just don't tweet
this and go Defcon 3 on Jewish people
tomorrow you can still do that like
people are going to be reading that and
be like oh well honey it's gonna be hard
to get some sleep tonight
why you see this Kanye tweet he's gonna
go death guess deathcon three on us
also I'm a bit like
saying your sleep what grown man says
he's sleepy even you just say I'm tired
I'm a bit sleepy tonight but when I wake
up
I'm going Defcon 3 on Jewish people
what's deathcon 3 um what is that is
that like a Star Wars thing
the death convention
military thing wow not going military
just a rapper a guy who makes shoes
a guy who's making a guy who makes two
big clothing
death counter I just hey man you can't
sit on Twitter again
[Music]
can't be added to Semitic dude that's
the whole thing I don't think I don't
like when people say white people can't
be racist that's like saying like black
people can't be at this matter dude why
wait wait no sorry
people say you can't be racist against
white people is what they say which is
my whole thing is dude it's got to stop
at the point where if anyone's being
judging you because of the color of you
or something like that you're I don't
give a [ __ ] dude you're racist I don't
the history is bad I get it I get it
it's harder for black people 100 but
dude you can be racist against white
people period I know that we actually
can't be there's people like Scholars
will be like yes you can't be because I
go like this
uh and honestly that makes me go Defcon
3. I would go death come forward to that
but
I don't know how many death cons there
are but I would do the maximum death I
would go right under the maximum death
count for that if somebody said you
couldn't be racist against me
um
so that's that let's look at some of
these uh deserve it scales
which really be peak in my interest you
know what I mean because of how people
fall down and we love it
my son blocked his head the other day
and he almost cried and I hugged him and
I said it's gonna be okay it's okay it's
okay and it was okay and you I should
take a deep breath he goes and he didn't
he didn't cry and it was [ __ ] so
awesome he was in the middle of our
crocodile I keep talking about la la
crocodile but you know what dude we were
watching it and I had to take him out
for a little bit and he said let's go
out there I went out there and then as
soon as we went out I had to pee I peed
and he said let's go back into the movie
theater and I was like okay and he went
there and he [ __ ] sell crawled all
over the seats you can't win hey guys
that's the end of the episode today for
YouTube if you want the raw the uncut
version uh the uncensored version go on
over to patreon.com Chris Dalia and you
can get the episode in its entirety and
you can also get the extra episodes that
we've done I think we've done like
almost 20 of them at this point uh so go
on over and pay six dollars and get all
of that all of the episodes if you're
going on a road trip it's phenomenal
it's also good to gift it dude the
holidays are coming up but also dude uh
you get extra content like we do review
mode we do I did a podcast with Kristen
on there and uh all you never know what
we're doing over there okay until it
happens but we have a good time so
patreon.com crystalia thank you
[Music]